i think philosophy is almost by
definition the most important
[Music]
intellectual endeavor there is but and
this is being a real snide [ __ ] i
don't the thing is really unfortunate
people that actually engage in it
have not been trained properly
this is part two of the conversation
with the great david wallpark part one
is in the description and i recommend
that you watch that first in order to
gain an overview of the professor's work
in this podcast we cover what the
definition of an observer is and we also
cover many audience questions including
those from the inventive and prolific
chris langan carl fristen and neil seth
and kevin knuth among others we also
cover a topic virtually never touched on
in the public discussion of the
foundations of mathematics and
philosophy called algorithmic
information theory david believes that
the only unquestionable results in
philosophy are those found in
algorithmic information theory so we
perform a cursory examination of it
lastly david makes a distinction between
the what consciousness and the how
consciousness personally i'm generally a
fan of disambiguation and think that
many philosophical problems exist
because of a befuddlement of our
conflicted language which later
generations disembroil and then they
think back and wonder why previous
generations were so confused in fact
john verveiki also separates
consciousness into adjectival
consciousness and adverbial
consciousness click on the timestamp in
the description if you'd like to skip
this intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm
a torontonian filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of the
variegated terrain of theories of
everything from a theoretical physics
perspective but as well as analyzing
consciousness and seeing its potential
connection to fundamental reality
whatever that is essentially this
channel is dedicated to exploring the
underived nature of reality the
constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even noble to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topics
of psychology consciousness physics etc
the channel's themes then do consider
going to the discord and the subreddit
which are linked in the description
there's also a link to the patreon that
is patreon.com
kirchheim uncle if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliance for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are league groups continuous lead
groups visit brilliant.org
toe t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the toe podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy professor why don't
you explain what laplace's demon is and
then why there's an impossibility result
about the existence of laplace's demon
okay
um not surprisingly um laplace's demon
is named for a simone laplace
um worked towards the end of the 18th
century mostly the early 19th century
he was among other things the first
person to really use bayesian statistics
he applied it to planetary motion
to try to infer what the actual um true
or
make more accurate estimates of the true
parameters of the emotion the planets is
um a whole bunch of um uh
mathematics um that we use that um
undergraduates will be using in um uh
the physics and math majors and so on
has his name involved so he's a very
very bright guy
now he was um working at a time when
people thought that everything was
ultimately newtonian classical physics
well before relativity well before
quantum mechanics
and
he
realized that in that paradigm
if you give a um a brilliant scientist
or a demon
sufficient information about these state
of the world at present
they can predict exactly what the state
of the world would be in all of its
details arbitrarily far into the future
um and this was true before
not only many notions of quantum
mechanics or relativity but also before
people knew about chaos or any of the
other kinds of phenomena that have been
uncovered in the 20th century that might
make one think that apostles demon can't
quite hold
um
so that's his demon one
the work that i've been involved with on
inference devices
one of the it's almost kind of a trivial
but one of the kinds of things that it
uncovers
is that regardless of what actually the
laws of physics are um regardless of
whether it's got anything to do with
what's currently called the standard
model whether it's quantum physics
um whether it's classical physics it
could have been newtonian it could have
been newtonian where there was no chaos
it could have been exactly the paradigm
that um laplace was thinking in
but even given that kind of a
hypothesis
his demon could not exist there's a
logical fallacy
embedded in the very notion
and that is actually intuitively it's
quite simple you can set it up in terms
of um
what sometimes called a cretin's liars
paradox some people say
pepa amenities
was the person who first wrote it down
others say it actually um has earlier
roots still
but um basically you can set it up in
such a way that
they're um even in a classical universe
where it's a finite one even let's make
it be finite with no chaos
you can very easily um construct
possible questions concerning the future
state of that universe
that laplace could not possibly get
correct
by definition whatever his prediction is
it would be exactly wrong
precisely because applause is part of
the universe that is the key
um so it's not too hard to convince
yourself of why that might be true
and um
we can work through the details if you
want
i don't know how you might actually get
this out to your audience
but um there's
um some work
i can show a slide later you can just
send me those
yeah maybe we can do that later um
yeah let's get to all that later um
so in any case the um
so that is part of a general inference
devices really grew out of
the desire to quantify and build a
formal structure
that goes beyond this impossibility
argument of the possible demon which by
the way i have not actually proven it to
you but certainly not in the generality
that i stated it about how it's
impossible where it doesn't depend on
the laws of physics
so what inference devices is about that
whole formalism
at root what it says when it first
notices is that um
let's go for let's adopt the one
attribute of reality
that most card carrying physicists
certainly cosmologists
would ascribe to
independent of the detailed physical
theory which is that the um human beings
themselves are physical systems
so this is so it's really a perspective
that turns conventional philosophy on
its head
in that
rather than try to understand what
various
um what our scientific theories might be
um in terms of well are we just
discovering the external reality or like
an instrumentalist would say we're
discovering useful variables for making
predictions about the external reality
and so on
instead to practicing physicists as i
said especially those who deal with for
example cosmology
rather
physical reality is the starting point
and then you derive human beings
as an approximation to some of the
equations and physics of that of the
actual true world
so to whatever degree
those
epi phenomena of human beings
can themselves make accurate theories
about this physical system they're
embedded with that's a secondary
question so rather than starting from
the perspective of humans
saying what um
what is it that we're talking about when
we talk about science how does it relate
to the external reality
the physicists make that be a very very
secondary minor question saying let's
start with the physical reality
then human beings are just one of the
phenomena in that physical reality that
we can describe completely and if we
wanted to we could drill down into even
more
my minute
semi-trivial questions like well some of
those human beings they call themselves
philosophers of science
and they're looking at these various
things that other human beings called
scientists that come up with
and they're trying to worry about how
they might relate to this underlying
physical reality and yet that's all well
and good but it's
very very secondary to the presumption
that
physical reality is just the set of
mathematical questions and we humans and
all of our
conundrums are just something that comes
out from it
so if you adopt that perspective
then you can go very very
broad scale on some of the issues that
are addressed in philosophy of science
and associate branches of philosophy
called epistemology
you can say
given any agent doesn't have to be a
human being that is
situated in that physical reality
so the states of its brain are simply a
subset of they only
how to phrase it so the physical reality
to allow it to have any kinds of laws
we will reduce it to a set which is the
set of all possible
histories of reality through all time
what is called a world line in
relativity
so
um
there's going to be one world line
in which you kurt are wearing a um a red
off-reddish jacket
there's another world line that would be
the same laws of physics but it's
another element in the set in which
you're right now wearing instead of more
brownish jacket
these are both world lines
that are elements of the set of all
possible world line histories
so if i then look at the particular
world line in which kurt is sitting in
that so if i look at the particular
event that curt is right now
sitting in that chair
that actually selects out a subset of
all possible world lines
there will be some in which you are
sitting in that chair and someone which
you are not
so that event is really just a subset of
the set of all possible world lines of
the universe
in addition
the um event where you pose to yourself
a question like
what happens when um two bodies are
gravitationally attracted to one another
and have the following masses of
momentum come within a certain distance
of one another
the set of realities in which you pose
that question
is a subset of all possible world lines
the set of realities in which you give a
possible particular answer to that
question
is another subset
and also we can presume that the set of
physical realities in which your answer
is correct
and which your answer is wrong
are yet other subsets
so what this sets up so to speak
um is that there's a relationship
between these sets where one subset of
all the realities where you pose a
question
another one is where you give a
particular answer both of which are just
physical states of your brain and then
there's a third one which has to do with
the actual
physical system you are asking this
question about
the answer to your question may in some
of those describe that physical system
accurately and they may do it
inaccurately they might be wrong in
other words
it turns out that just by making that
decomposition that everything about you
are making a prediction
is involves questions answers and truths
we can also say everything about your
making an observation you are right now
observing
something
which you can be then posing a question
to yourself what am i observing
you can then have an answer to that what
am i um what do i think in response to
that question
and then it can be the actual truth and
these again are just three subsets of
all possible world lines
whether your observation is correct or
is distorted
will be determined by the overlap
between these world lines
so everything you observe
everything you predict
everything that you remember which is
another example of this
everything you could control you could
reach out your hand and try to be having
the question
where is this pencil going to be
one minute from now and you are making
it so
anything in this most broad sense
imaginable of what um in philosophy is
called epistemology of you of your
knowledge
about this world about whether your
knowledge could be correct or could be
or wrong
we can reduce all analysis of it
to saying how is it that these three
subsets
relate to one another
based upon that so notice that this
level of formalism we're far beyond any
specifics like is it a universe where
quantum mechanics holds or classical
mechanics hold the universe could be
finite the universe could not have chaos
on it it doesn't matter
nor does it matter how you are
making your
questions and answers whether it be by
prediction predicting whether the sun
will come up tomorrow or um what's going
to be happening with those two
gravitation gravitating bodies i
alluded to before or if it comes via
observation or even memory
or directly control any form of these is
being covered by the structure of three
overlapping subsets
it turns out that once you do that that
all that is needed is that
formalism of three overlapping subsets
that you can get a whole bunch of
impossibility results
and one of them to return to the point
that you were raising before has to do
with the apostles demon
you can say that laplace
is somebody asking a question
we can say that what that question
involves is his future answer itself
then there can be the answer he gives
and there can be reality and if
basically if laplace's questions of the
form will i not be thinking that the
answer is yes
one second from now
whatever answer he gives now you can set
up in such a way that his answer to his
question will actually be the opposite
of the truth
and it doesn't matter what kind of a
system he uses to make that future
prediction it doesn't matter if the
paradigm in which he was working of
classical non-chaotic finite physics was
correct
his
demon is in this very formal very broad
sense going to be wrong he has a demon
will be wrong and there will still be
instances of such
erroneousness
even if he builds a
demon that goes off and makes the
prediction on his behalf so if it's not
laplace's demon it's not the plus is the
demon he makes it even the same kind of
thing goes through
so that's the way that we can actually
formalize the very simple notion of
laplace
this says demon is a flawed concept in
its very
presumption it's very structured
independent of the rules of reality
in such a way that actually allows us to
then derive things like the monotheism
theorem and the deism theorem and these
other things about how many omnipotent
entities might a physical reality have
independent of the laws of physics it
sounds like what you said is that there
exists a question such that he will
necessarily be incorrect so when i was
first reading about this i thought that
it was going to go along the lines of
there exists configurations of physical
space such that he won't necessarily be
correct but you're saying no there's a
question such that he will necessarily
be wrong no matter what no matter what
question answer pair
he comes up with it will be wrong if it
is supposed to be related to physical
reality remember there are three things
there's your question your answer and
then whatever the truth of the matter is
and so there are ways of setting up that
though that triple i say i see so
we can be guaranteed
that um if that question answer in
reality is supposed to be something that
concerns the future state of his brain
then um no matter what the details are
we can always
set up a question in such a way that the
answer
will not actually be the same thing as
reality says but will be the opposite
question when you stated it it reminded
me of the liar's paradox or gerda
have you found any impossibility results
that are on more trivial questions when
i say trivial i mean recall back in the
early 1900s when girdle came up with
this some mathematicians said sure in
some
special cases there exist statements
that you can't prove but it's not like
those are useful statements or
statements that we talk about they're
incredibly contrived statements that was
a critique back at the time it's no
longer critique but i'm wondering so is
your impossibility result does it cover
those non-trivial statements sorry those
two
this particular one about the process
demon
i would say is one of the more of the
trivial ones here's a more interesting
one
um
[Music]
and i'm going to state it in very loaded
language what we were discussing in the
previous podcast about you should not
use terms
afterwards you and i had this um back
and forth where it's called the uh
persuasion um definition that i guess
where you define something some way in a
particular way so you know that you can
you define out of it everything that
makes it interesting the first place but
be that resume this is actually not
completely an exercise of that but
so let's define an inference device
as a question answer pair so you are an
inference device a computer can be an
inference device
um my dog
whose name is choco and he's the most um
amazing dog in the universe
i'm just to make sure that people are
aware of that is that a true fact is
that true you have a dog named taco yeah
i named him choco he looks somewhat like
the canyon
um
he's a good a mutt somewhere off the
streets of l.a
he's got a bunch of long-haired
chihuahua in him and other things and he
is
it is really unfortunate that he's been
sterilized
because he is so gentle he's so good
with people and he is so smart
i never trained him to do anything um
but he just can tell by my tone of voice
he took after the gentle and smart
nature of his owner
oh don't i wish i could say that and
rather everything that i treat my
deepest wisdom about life all of it i
learned by watching him say no don't be
more like him but then you'll be able to
get through this as well um but in any
case these are all inference devices
so you can say that well some inference
devices let's
um and different inference devices are
going to be able to make correct
inferences about different things
um we have this problem of them trying
to make these inferences about
themselves um my
[ __ ] flyers paradox um apply to
themselves but that but let's we can
assume that they can make um good
inferences about almost everything else
but and and notice that the notion of an
inference device it's not just being
able to make predictions and also how to
even into control
so for example um a really strong person
who's able to move things physically
part of what they can do and
successfully them as an inference device
is actually move those objects
that way atlas
the greek odd would have been they or
titan was he i'll forget what was this
yeah was the one with the world on his
shoulders yeah yeah i just can't
remember he don't think he was a god i
think he may have been a titan but i
don't remember
um the titans were the predecessors of
the gods in any case um he would would
have been an inference device a very
strong one
so um one can then so basically
you can conjecture
that there the universe might have a
god in the sense of an inference device
that can control
and accurately predict everything except
for in the case of laplace's demon
that it can go after everything else and
do it correctly
so as long as you're not asking god this
puget of god or goddess whatever it
would be deity
deity dude we'll call it deity doo dee
dee so long as you're not asking so long
as dd is not asking itself questions
along the lines of what will i not be
asking a second from now
so long as dee dee is asking things like
oh well is um adam going to eat this
apple that was just prefer proffer to
him by eve
so and so long as dede is doing things
like
reaching down his hand
and writing on walls parting red seas
doing things that are more interesting
from the non-judeo-christian religions
they in some ways had much more
interesting deities than
just the standard yahweh from
judeo-christian islamic religion but in
any case abramek
we can suppose that there is a universe
that does have such a dd in it
um
and so with where it would be actually
correct in everything that it says about
everything in its own universe
except that doesn't have this weird kind
of structure related to itself
that it's correct
now let's consider the question though
could we have two dd's
and it turns out that we need to um in
addition to these two deities as an
aside david i want to make sure these
deities are they embedded in the
physical universe yes that's the key
that's the key but this physical
universe itself
you can define that however you want and
whatever the deity is so long as it
itself
it does things at various times and
we're not even saying requiring it to be
lawful in any sense just that we can
write down a set of world lines
and those word lines are by definition
they are the record of what the deity
its state is across
all space and time is in one of these
world lines
so this might very well extend to
supernatural
variables that are not embedded in the
laws of physics it doesn't even matter
there's no presumption here that the
deity is in any sense lawful
bound by laws
it's simply that it can that it states
um we can be recorded
and in a certain sense if not then
i mean that almost means if by
definition non-consequential
you know wittgenstein's platitude about
that which you cannot talk shut the hell
up
certainly would come to play there
because we're in any case
um
but so now let's consider the
um possibility that there are two
separate deities
and now in addition to um
abusing the term deity i'm going to now
abuse another term
i mean even worse which is the one with
the ones we were talking about yesterday
which is free will
and so this is what i'm going to say i'm
going to say kurt you're an inference
device i'm an inference device
we both have free will if the following
property holds
whatever state david might be in
it's possible for kurt to it's not
somehow there is a
element of the states of the set
of all possible world lines in which
david is in that state
and kurt is in state a
there's also another one in which david
is in that state and kurt is in state b
there's another one in which david is in
that state and kurt is state c
so basically
the definition of free will is that the
state that david is in
does not rule out
the possibility of kurtz being in
various states in that sense
it's not a matter of i'm controlling you
it's not even having anything to do with
physical correlation
it's simply saying that i cannot um be
in a state like for example where i
have in my head the edict curt
is not wearing a jacket
you could that either could be true or
it could be false in that sense you are
free
and conversely i am free in that sense
of you so as long as we have free will
not sense not definition
and i it's very very much
tongue-in-cheek for me to call that free
will but if we have free will in that
sense
at least one moment
then it is impossible to have two
deities
you cannot have two deities
in the sense that they can both
have perfectly accurate inferences by
everything other themselves if they both
have free will at least once that's
incredibly interesting does an
impossibility result against more than
one god yes
yep that's why it's called the
monotheism theorem
it might be that we are in a universe in
which you could have one god who knows
i'm not going to go there i mean my
personal
um feeling uh
conclusions on it are that in our
particular universe no
um but there could but there is no
reason why i think the the concept
itself is not inherently
self-contradictory like apostles demon
there could be universes i would say
there's no sense in which we can
actually
rule them out in fact in which there are
deities um but there cannot be any of
them
that support two deities
so we might be in one of those ones in
which there is a deity who knows but we
can't be one which is more than one and
when you say there can't be two
omniscient to deities
there can't be two that have free will
ah
so you could have one where there's zeus
and hera
but
um zeus can always be in a particular
state
that restricts hera for being in in some
of her particular states
interesting in that sense she does not
have free will of him at one particular
time one particular state of zeus
it's just not going to be any possible
um
world line in any of the um uh universe
in our universe in which hera
is in um one of her particular states
there's some limitation my being one
particular state at one particular time
it could causes a restriction on the
possible states that you could be in at
that time and if that's true that we
have no free will have you heard of
norton's dome
norton's dome um
i think i
did a while ago drinking a bell but i
can't bring it up sure it's a thought
experiment about newtonian mechanics and
it's to show that newtonian mechanics
isn't deterministic even though it's
often said it is and the reason is there
are certain configurations you can set
up such that there is not a unique
answer to the differential equations you
know ordinarily in physics just for
people to know one of the reasons why
mathematicians quibble with physicists
is that this is hand wave and gloss over
many details and so one of them is
whenever we have an ordinary
differential equation we tend to say
there's uniqueness in existence however
that's contingent on something called
the lipschitz continuity and if you
don't have lift shit's continuity you
don't necessarily have a unique solution
so you basically set up a certain
situation with a ball on a dome and the
equation for the dome is fairly simple
it's almost like a parabola and then it
turns out one solution is it stays there
forever the zero velocity initially and
then another solution is at some point t
and the time t is not specified it goes
down some route and any one of them so
that's extremely interesting let's
imagine we live in a newtonian world is
that related to free will would you say
or is that not related to free will
that's something different i know a free
will forget about the sense of intention
interacting with the laws of nature to
produce that effect yeah the norton's
dome it's also um i think it was
actually sabine
um who has a um
one of her fqxi essays that she points
out that chaos
is what is in some sense it can be a
much stronger phenomenon than people
understand and that you can set up
physical systems
in which the chaos is to such a degree
that actually passes a certain point in
time you cannot there it is not defined
but the state of the system will be
after that so that's i think that's the
context in which i ran across it it's
also they're related things the work
that goes back to um two people called
parel and richards
um those were physicists who as well
known that for example the three-body
problem
um where even if you do so there you do
have the standalone continuity and so on
you've got gravitational attraction so
on
um you can
set it up to be a what's called a
universal turing machine
you basically what you do is you encode
the um input
tape to that turing machine
into
the actual precise initial conditions of
these three bodies
and then by reading the appropriate
bits of the state of the system at some
future time
you can figure out what that universal
turing machine state of its tape would
be at that time
what this means is that you can feed in
a configuration that's actually the
halting problem
so that that physical system in fact it
violates the church turing thesis
that that physical system its um as
state in the future would not be
computable
so it's a very closely related kind of
result
the impossibility results that i'm
describing
are stronger in that they don't
presuppose differential equations
they don't suppose any of that kind of
lawful structure whatsoever
um so that's the sense in which they
would hold no matter what the laws of
physics are
and that's this that is for that reason
as well that they encompass any possible
supernatural
um uh
phenomenology um
impact on the real world not no matter
how you might even think about it
because it's they're just subsets of the
set of all possible world lines and
world lines
in this sense
they're just a um
themselves
are a set of events in a completely
arbitrary
sense what the word event means it
doesn't even presuppose space time
um really the mathematics just says here
is a set i'm going to call the elements
the set world lines
because that's what they happen to
correspond to in our kind of world but
they're just things
and um there and everything that's got
that we as humans would call rules and
laws concerning them
has to do with things like um
observation operators on them and
projections and things like that but
that's all extra structure just the
topology of it the fact that you have
these interlocking subsets that itself
has many consequences
one of which is the monotheism theorem
you could maybe have a god
but you can't have more than one
um i
i view that
the way that i
how to phrase this
i play a bunch of fast and loose games
when i describe this result
on the one hand almost to protect myself
in intellectual discourse
i want to say that i'm phrasing that
theorem very much tongue-in-cheek
and there's an element of truth to that
but without
making a
firm
declaration
i would say quite honestly
that this does
prove that by any notion of a deity in
any of the world's religions and any
philosopher might ever have come up with
no you can't have more than one this
actually does prove monotheism
so if you push me to the wall i'm going
to go tongue-in-cheek and say well i'll
be using my definitions
but there's a large part of me that's
thinking that no in fact this does prove
that you can't have more yet polytheism
is ruled out sorry
this sounds like a great time to talk
about what an observer is
so an observer in this sense
is basically an inference device if
we're talking so an observer we could be
thinking about there's many different
frameworks the way that i know how to
phrase this okay this is a digression um
or a diversion i'll i'll come back i'm
circling around um so
when i
do
my own
personal philosophizing if that's the
world when i built when i
construct configure my own
internal
dwelling that's got to do with
that i call the philosophy house
so to speak
what what it really amounts to is the
following that there are different
i'm almost exclusively interested in
metaphysics i frankly couldn't care less
about philosophy of art for example i
think it's an oxymoron philosophy of
morality i think harsanyi's got some
interesting things to say
rawls um less so singer i think has some
interesting things to say
but not all that much more than that um
but so mostly it's metaphysics in other
words what is reality and so on and so
forth
and basically as you strip and what
philosophy house
is built upon is the understanding that
you can do certain investigations where
you make certain assumptions
then when you weaken those assumptions a
lot of it falls apart and you get to a
deeper level of reality where there's
less structure
weaken assumptions and you keep going
down and down and down until the whole
thing actually eats itself
so
up at one level
i'm more than happy to be a steadfast
card-carrying member of the school of
people call themselves scientists
scientific realists whatever you might
want to call it um
then at another level
you can start to say well what is
reality you can't even define it
and
you start to then start worrying about
things like inference devices you can
then say wait a second combine what you
just
said about no reality is more real than
any other that all of them are just
different these subsets
of possible universes that
you can have define these inference
devices structures that's all that any
reality is
that none is any
is a privilege over any other
doesn't that also can't you also then
apply that to your own reasoning your
own question answer process
and conclude that that itself is going
to be illegitimate in a sort of apost
demons kind of sense
so you've just concluded that no reality
is privileged above any other
but in doing so if you want to strip
down the very last remaining assumption
you are not allowed to assume that your
reasoning process itself is somehow
proof against
um that kind of conclusion
and so as was put in i think as one of
the hitchhikers guides
um uh little um
[Music]
episodes that everything vanishes in a
proof of logic
um and that's where you would ultimately
end up going
so the reason i mention that is when you
say the word observation
it can mean very different things
depending on where we are in this whole
edifice
this philosophy house where we're
stripping out assumptions and so on
in the context of inference devices
observation is just like prediction
control or memory
for that matter
it's just a way for you to be posing
questions you then have an observation
device
that is providing you answers and what
the
things like the apostles demon theorem
and all these kinds of things prove to
you
is that you no matter what the
observation device is they're always
going to be situations where the answer
gives you is wrong
so that's what observation means in the
context of inference devices it means
other things in other contexts
um
but
in the structure of instruments devices
note that prediction and memory are
identical
so
this is something that has to do with
the block model of the universe that we
think we were talking about last time
the second law and the psychological era
of time
memory
is just retrodiction it's a prediction
about the past rather than the future
that we suppose
for reasons having to do with the second
law
um has to be
much more accurate at least some of our
memory than our predictions why do you
say that it's a prediction about the
past rather than a statement about the
past ah because we have no way of
knowing it's true it's a statistical
it's identical there is no privileged
arrow of time
this is um something that physicists
have been wrestling with especially
cosmologists i think i mentioned last
time there's a 1973
book by paul davies the physics of time
asymmetry and sean carroll's got some
nice stuff in this
and there's i i have a paper in i think
it was
1992 in the international journal of
theoretical physics
on these kinds of things there is no
sense in which the past is more real in
the future
all moments are just as real as one
another and all that we are doing as
scientists or as people remembering
is making statistics predictions in the
statistic sense
despite that um uh prefix the word pre
addiction
from a
scientific point of view from the point
of view of the laws of physics
there is no difference between a
prediction and a retrodiction
they are both using
null data at the present to make a
statistical estimate
of the state of a variable at a time
other than the present
so retrodiction you could be wrong
and in fact
that's of course um a whole another body
of the
work and things we could discuss about
is how in fact the mind very often is
wrong
and there's implanted memories and just
generally fallibility of memory and
all this business about how
consciousness is a
just so story that we concoct
to try to give us the illusion that
we're actually in control that we have
some memory accurate memory of the past
and that both are actually erroneous
um but so anyway
memory is just retrodiction
and so it is as prone subject to all
these impossibility results as any of
the inference device
so what that means in particular is what
the plus was only thinking forward in
time
the impossibility and so he wouldn't
even think there was an issue for having
of having to construct a demon
that would actually predict the past you
just simply say you you remember the
past
and so sure your memories are 100
accurate
in point of fact
no
according to these impossibility results
for the same reason that laplace cannot
predict the future with 100 accuracy
it's impossible to build a 100 percent
accurate
memory device
memories will always be valuable will
always be wrong there's always going to
be one other memories and recording that
device which could be your head
that's wrong
is there a relationship between the no
free lunch theorem and the limits on
inference devices
very good question so i found
somewhat to my bemusement that a lot of
the
stuff that i
stuff yeah the stuff that i am drawn to
investigate the things that i chew on
have to do with impossibilities
no free lunch is one of them inference
devices is another one
as i think i mentioned to you
the notion that mathematics itself might
be inherently sarcastic which is you uh
offline we discussed about how that's
related to intuitionism
some of the ideas of nikolas um gisen
and intuitionism of course
traces back to brower
um a great mathematician the 20th
century
and i think that there are some
potentially some possibility results
there as well
but all of these i suspect have to be
related to one another
um i've
that's on my
i've got everybody's got to do lists
and that's on one of my longer term
greatest size font
so to speak to do lists
is figure out
how to integrate these impossibility
results there's also ones that i haven't
that weren't the ones that i came up
with
there are the impossibility results um
that are involved with that have to do
with touring machines and girdle and so
on
um you think they're all related
well for example i'm doing some work at
a very very
low burner i wish i could do it um more
intensely
um on trying to
take you exploit the church touring
thesis
um to be able to say that in and as
within the context of inference devices
to say that if there is a universal
turing machine it's going to be
inference device
and can the and the impossibility
results concerning inference devices
do they for example tell us something
like you can't have two
um uh
perfectly accurate universal turing
machines
do they say do they provide another way
to prove the halting theorem
and so that's on my to-do list to see if
they might be integrated that way
um another
interesting thing is that the inference
devices
structure that i was describing to you
um
had no probability distributions over it
we were just talking about subsets of um
the set of all possible world lines
well let's slap down a probability
distribution
we can now modify some of our
definitions of what it means to infer
something
accurately
to be
to infer with a higher than certain
probability of being correct
we can then say well over all possible
probability distributions
so right so that what that means is that
rather than the impossibility results of
an inference devices that concern for
example two deities
instead what you start talking about the
probability distribute of all the worst
case
probability
that both deities could be um uh correct
or was the best case probability that
they could be correct over all possible
probability distributions
so rather than saying it's impossible
for them to both always be overall
interesting
yeah
and guess what you actually get some
results out of that that look a little
bit like the heisenberg uncertainty
principle is this published work um i
think it's mentioned in one of my papers
but it's both that and the turing
machine stuff
very tentative
there's a lot more that needs to be done
and that i
want to get to at some point i mean
there's this meta optimization problem
for
people who are so very very lucky like
as me
that society provides us the resources
to go off and
well play is the way it feels like to me
but for us for people who are so
i wouldn't use the word plus i mean i
mean fortunate but fortunate yes people
who are so fortunate
um there's this optimization question of
well there's all these things that you
do want to work on
you've only got some finite number of
years left you don't even know what they
are
prioritize dude or do that as the case
might be
and so i'm not sure so at some point yes
i do want to work on these things but
the question is when and how and how to
get the time and if you can do it with
collaborators which i try to do and so
on and
it's one of the challenges of being
somebody who's as fortunate as i am is
what how best to use that fortune have
you heard of donald hoffman
no i don't think so okay donald hoffman
has an argument that says whatever we
see is not reality as it is oh yes yes
yes
um
i don't think i i've drilled into it i
don't think it really amounts to that
much
um to be quite honest yes let's hear why
um i'd have to
go back and review my notes um
he seemed to be
i'm sorry
you um
so i've actually got i'm putting it up
right now for example my annotated
version of his
work
um
yeah and this is too much
i
if you want to have a splice in from a
third podcast i could
research it but i don't remember why
that's one of the other challenges um
being fortunate is you have to very
quickly come to decisions about whether
it makes sense for you to be spending
any effort drilling down on things
so yeah i did look into his stuff and i
wasn't very impressed so there's one
particular article of his that you think
i should maybe look at rather than
whatever i did look at if you could just
email that to me
i'll see if there's anything different
about that one
sure that's a quick aside
my background's not computer science as
you know whenever i've skimmed the
church turing thesis it seems more like
a definition of what it means to compute
rather than a theorem per se
it's very close to that it's very close
to that there's a question of whether
it's ultimately vacuous or not there's
something called the physical church
touring thesis
where instead we people say things like
you cannot build a physical computer
that can do that
that implements algorithms
that can come to conclusions that would
not be um possible to do
on a physical
turing machine
and it's squirrely to even define it
there there are different definitions
you can find in the literature
scott aronson actually has a nice
video at like two hours long where he
talks about different um
challenges to the physical church during
thesis
one of the reasons i recall that david
deutsch first started working in quantum
computation his original paper
was to try to say that well if the
physical church touring thesis can be
either fully ironclad formalized and or
i'm established as actually a law of
nature
that means we have to be able to express
computation in purely quantum mechanical
systems because quantum mechanics is the
law of nature
so that was a large part as i understand
it of his impetus for starting to work
on what now has become called quantum
computation
um
so but yes you're correct that the
church touring thesis as it was
understood
say in the middle of the 20th century
seemed very dangerously close to simply
being a definition rather than actually
a statement about the physical world
so before we get to the audience
questions
you mentioned
in one of your talks by the way during
the break i did quickly remind myself
about um professor hoffman
okay
yeah and uh so what i understand and my
take on
his work so in a nutshell
um he's a neuroscientist and
in a um extension of what we were
talking about earlier a vast um
elaboration of the notion that
um uh consciousness and so on and so
forth it's all a fable
um he has been doing a lot of work
showing that in particular
our understanding of the external world
is completely concocted
that it's whatever our
century apparatus is going to think is
actually most effective
um
how to phrase it our sentry apparatus is
going to be telling us
precisely whatever natural selection
finds out by trial and error
is the best thing to tell us to get us
to act in an efficient way
as far as our reproductive success is
concerned
that which is telling us to do that
might have nothing really to do with any
kind of an external physical reality
it's kind of an elaboration of all the
um aspects that what you think you are
seeing for example you are not it's all
being filled in with what's called
predictive coding
in its broadest sense in the
neuroscience community
and so my understanding of his work
was that he has done some interesting
things related to that particular
scientific issue
but then um sort of uh
well frankly puffs it up
as to saying something about there is no
objective reality and so on and so forth
it's
no rather our human being fallible
perception of reality
um it can be very very different
and natural selection in fact you would
say which should make it be very very
different
from what we would from what an actual
reality is
okay now before we get to some audience
quest and just so you know as an aside i
don't believe donald hoffman although
maybe you have a different paper i don't
believe he indicates that there is no
reality he does say what you said which
is that our relationship to that reality
because the way that he constructs
reality it looks strange the way that
it's like three it's like agents
interacting with one another etc that's
the truth
that was just based on a quick skim
reminding myself from i have to put
after you admit the very pedestrian
source which is quantum magazine that's
okay and one of your talks i think in
one of your fqxi talks you mentioned
that some of the most profound results
in philosophy come from algorithmic
information theory yeah and
coincidentally i'll be speaking to
gregory chayton in a few weeks
so okay
please explain to me why you think that
okay i can use one of um uh greg
chetan i mean he does insist that be
pronounced chaitin rather than shaytan
um
he's a very interesting fellow in many
ways and he's done some great work one
of his
results in fact i think does have this
character to it he's got an
impossibility theorem
which is um basically it says that there
is
a integer
um
l
such that we can never ever prove
that any particular
[Music]
um uh
computation
that we would want to do any particular
string
has komogorov complexity greater than l
okay there is some such integer and
he actually has an estimate of it as i
believe based upon this programs of
being
4000 if you're using lisp as your turing
machine
um
but think about what that means
there's going to be this number like ml
which is like say 4 000 that's saying
that you know anything that's longer
than 4 000 bytes
um so you cannot prove that the komodo
complexity of any particular string
is going to be greater than 4000 bytes
we know
that there's a very finite number of uh
strings that have less than four
thousand bytes
at most depending on the grammar and
syntax of your
language and so on it would be two to
the four thousand which would be a big
number but
i'm not it's very very finite
so that means that there's an infinite
number of strings
that exist
whose komodo complexity
we can never actually determine
so we can never know what is the
simplest program
size
for determining the simplest program
for actually doing those calculations
it's an amazing restriction on what we
human beings can do
to give you another example this is one
that i know best from my a book by um
lee and vitani it's kind of like the
bible and these turing machine things
you can actually
prove the existence of a function
from the integers to the integers
which is always increasing it never it
never sometimes will stay the same but
it never goes down and eventually gets
to infinity
such that every function you can
possibly compute no matter how you do it
that is also always increasing and gets
to infinity
will be strictly greater than this
you wouldn't have even thought there is
such a limitation that could even make
sense
do whatever you want say okay here's a
function which
it has the value one
for the first million numbers from one
through a million it's got the value one
then it's got the value two but that's
for the next million to the millions
okay
you know make it be whatever you want
every rule that you can put down for how
to construct this
it's going to actually be getting to
infinity faster than this other function
which is a very strange thing and it's
reality
it's one of the most fundamental
philosophical results in the sense that
philosophy
should not be biased towards what we
human beings consider to be compelling i
find it that
impossibility results in general
and of these sorts in particular
they are very deep philosophy whether or
not we even appreciate they had meaning
before we came across them
um another one what was the name of that
one that second one
oh this is i don't even think it has a
name
i don't even think it has a name i can
point you to the chapter and yeah
um it's but there's another one that for
example um scott aronson has a nice blog
post on this it's called the busy beaver
function
and he's actually recently written some
uh papers on it as well
and this is kind of the flip side of
what i just said
that
let's try to make the fastest increasing
function possible
so you curt
say that well for the value one it's got
the value one for the value 2 it's got
the value 10 to the 10 to the 10.
for the value 3 it's got
white height for the value 2 but now
itself
make it be whatever you want
there is always going to be something
which is called the busy beaver function
which is actually increasing faster than
the the fastest increasing function you
can write down in other words there's an
upper limit
to how to what there's an upper limit to
the speed of increase of any function
from the introduce the integers that you
can possibly define
it's it's in a certain sense it's
mind-boggling that there's that kind of
a limitation on what we can do i'm not
understanding it correctly so at first
the way that i understood what you said
is that you have a function that's
increasing and then you can make it
increase faster but then there's a bound
there's about i can write down an
increase i can write down the definition
of a function
and it exists i can prove it exists
and it is an increasing function
and it will be increasing faster than
any function that you can possibly write
down
now i have a question about that like i
mentioned i'm speaking to someone who's
an ultrafinitist an intuitionist and
they don't particularly like existence
proofs they like construction
yep and that's that is the foundation of
intuitionism i don't think that actually
nicholas gibson
that goes that far though i'm not sure
he might in some side eddy of one of his
papers
um but yeah that was the foundation they
don't like existence proofs they want a
um constructive proof only is this
constructed or you just showed the
existence of this one oh the busy beaver
function um
it has been constructed for the first
some number of values of what of the
integer so we know
for we can write down a busy beaver
function for one for two for three for
four and so on
up to some particular value but i think
that um in the busy beaver function in
its entirety
almost by definition no it can't be
constructed
because if it could be constructed you
kurt would construct it
that's the point that this thing exists
wait sorry i don't get that last my way
if it could be constructed i could
construct it what do you mean
um so the definition so if if it if by
construct if i construct a function we
mean you write down a program
that spits out its values
that's what we mean to construct a
function then the busy beaver function
is something that increases faster than
could be the output of any such program
you can write down oh okay okay okay
mean it's very very easy to define
and um
and the uh so in
it is purely an existence function that
you can't construct it but
i can define it very very easily
um it takes only a couple of sentences
that um to define what the thing is
so there are these kinds of results
which
i find in many ways
flabbergasting
because they're
if one adopts the church turing thesis
these are limitations on human thinking
and there are other ones and this is an
addition to all the ones like the
halting problem you know halting theorem
which is um very closely related to of
course some girls in completeness
theorem
and then there's rice's theorem and all
these other things
which
really
i think that the only actual results of
the only actual
philosophical advances that have been
made by humanity
are these kinds of results
everything else is not only questionable
um and is being questioned it is
ultimately going to be quicksand and
it's just going to be squishy and you're
not going to get anywhere
these are the only ones that we have
managed to generate so far these are it
folks
by definition they are the deepest
because they are
the full set of things that we have
actually established
incontrovertibly or as incontrovertible
as any um deductive logic could be for
mathematics
okay i'm going to send you a chat right
now let me know if you can pull it up on
your end or if it automatically gets
sent to you see there
well it's a big one okay yeah yeah okay
so the reason i'm sending it to you is
because i'm probably going to miss read
this and it's easier if you read along
with me oh these are questions from the
audience yes this is not live obviously
i'm just saying this is from before so
this question
we're now we're getting onto some
audience questions and this comes from
chris langan let's get to question
number two which says he prior to this
was was referencing how in your
definition of observer there's a
theological aspect because an observer
wants to preserve its own
self-organization properties
not required in the definition of
observer
it doesn't there's nothing in there
about what your goal is
there's nothing in there about
intentionality in any of the inference
devices work
it's just you could be observing by luck
you're predicted so it includes the case
where your predictions are correct by
pure luck
or maybe even worse you thought that you
were answering a different question from
the real one but you were screwed up in
your thinking you happened to
accidentally get the answers right well
no the impossibility results so you
can't even do it that way
you can't get there by averted vision so
to speak so there's nothing about um
what you mean
for the question to actually be about
then let's do number four your work
straddles the boundary between mind and
matter what about cartesian mind slash
matter dualism which says that mind and
matter are fundamentally different do
you agree or do you believe they're both
aspects of
i don't see there's anything useful to
be had with the cartesian mind matter
duelist
perspective remember what we were
talking about before about it
let me just complete the sentence
because the audience doesn't have access
so do you agree or do you believe that
they're both aspects of a single
underlying reality
okay i didn't see that second part in
the chat um
mind and matter um
okay so it's got to a degree i see um
it involves a little part a little bit
where we are in that philosophy house
and what level we've gone to and i'm
sitting there with all the assumptions
about of these sort of what i could very
loosely and inaccurately describe as
scientific realism
then there is zero reason to believe
that there's anything in mind that does
not matter
and in fact even most even people that i
think are frankly wrong about many
things like david chalmers
worrying about um about consciousness
means and qualia and sorry penrose as
well
penrose as well when he talks about the
mind
um even these people um uh
will
almost
uniformly
and almost in total
um accept that mind is ultimately matter
um so that
this is part of why i find qualia to
ultimately be a vacuous concept is that
if you do accept that
i don't see whether there really any
wiggle room
to worry about well what are your
subjective impressions then i'll amount
to which is essentially what the quote
hard question of conscience is about
so when i'm sitting up there
in my scientific reel as some room of
the house
um a mind is just a um
attribute of a matter
for the reasons that hoffman alludes to
dates um elucidates um dan dennett has
some great work all the
zombie within stuff
um what mind um thinks it knows about
matter actually is in many many ways
completely fallacious
um
then when i drill down below that of
course you start running into things
like solipsism brain in a vat brain of
that is a cutesy little thing that
freshmen debate and has kind of been
ignored in the academy
nobody has gotten a answer to that
challenge because you can't have one
instead what do you do is you assume
that no let's assume that we're not a
brain in a vat
and that's the basis for most of
metaphysics because you can't go beyond
that
but if you were to
not make that assumption if you as i
mentioned before you go through these
various rooms in the house of philosophy
by throwing out assumptions
if you don't make the a priori
assumption that what we are perceiving
is somehow
coupled to a reality that we are more
than a brain in the vat or matrix if you
wish to view it that way or whatever
then you're stuck right there and the
question of is there a duality between
mind and matter
um if we're going to allow that i'm a
brain in a vat
then um that question takes on
completely different um aspects to it
that
mind
becomes matter in a different sense and
you can
you can drill it down even further
and start saying that well in fact and i
think this is where ultimately the
quality of people the heart problem of
consciousness people are coming from
that ultimately
mind comes first and whether there is
even matter or not
is a tbd
or to put it in another way i could
define a universe in the sense of
inference devices
which arguably is only mind
um and there is no such thing as matter
so you know once we get down to the
level of inference devices where a
universe is just a set of world lines
essentially we're down at what's called
sometimes anti-structural realism
we've actually gone even further than
max tegmart's multiverses
and all that any of reality amounts to
is a
pattern
relating aspects of these world lines
laws of the universe are just patterns
which could at any time be violated or
not and once you get to that level
that's just patterns just mathematics
that reality
to a pawn on a chess board is the laws
of chess
because that's what it's reality is it's
almost definitional
then you have no such there is no
distinction between mind and matter or
anything else
it's all just patterns at that level
there is no distinction the distinction
between minor matter
they come to play with you put throw in
other assumptions
that put you in other
rooms in the philosophy house
so the answer depends where you want to
situate your self-interest original
assumptions you adopt
this question now comes from i just sent
it this question is carl fristen carl
fristen of the free energy principle
it is a compelling notion that systems
extract information from their
environment to maintain themselves far
from equilibrium but is this extraction
cause or consequence in other words are
non-equilibrium steady states a
consequence of observing or making
inferences about other systems and then
there's some pulse amble
um
[Music]
so this is touching on a huge body work
my primary body of research these days
which we've actually not discussed at
all
which is what is called
which is what's called stochastic
thermodynamics non-equilibrium
thermodynamics
um
carl right there is i think without
being sure without this actually being a
proper conversation is he's trying to
lead me into
saying things which basically justify
his notions of having with markov
blankets and so on and so forth
um
instead to make a plug for myself is a
paper that i wrote with a postdoc artemy
kolczynski
um
with the title has to do with semantic
information and non-equilibrium physics
in which we make the case that
without necessarily wanting to say that
they are living systems whether they are
conscious systems in a certain sense
interesting systems are those that are
what are at what are called
non-equilibrium steady states which is a
word that carl is using there
and that maintain themselves as being
non-equilibrium steady states
because of the information that they are
actually getting from the environment
getting from it in a precise sense of
conditional information flows
um
and i think that those are very
interesting systems to
investigate and that's a whole nother
body of work that i would like to
investigate
but in terms of which came first
i'm
is this extraction cause or consequence
to me it's actually much more
that there are systems which do have
that extraction
and i would say it's neither cause nor
consequence
um are non-equilibrium steady states a
consequence of observing other
systems and physicists can give a very
simple answer no i can define non-equi
but enough a way to make a
non-equilibrium steady state is to
simply hook up a system to two heat
baths at different temperatures
and it will go into what is called in
physics a non-equilibrium steady state
is observing anything
you could say it's in a certain sense
quote observing the two different
temperatures but
that
i think does basically expands the
definition of the term observed so it
includes everything
it is interacting with its external
world and there are aspects of it that
are describable by information theory
and i think to use words like causal or
um
observation in that context
can be a very very fraught thing
it's in danger of um uh being a deepity
as dan dennett calls it calls it
okay this next question comes from
professor anil seth of neuroscience
and he has a book out on consciousness
which i'll link in the description he
says ask david whether he thinks
consciousness is substrate independent
so
a silicone computer can be in principle
conscious and if so why and then as a
sub note with regard to free will i'm
always interested if they referring to
you david and anyone else if you david
realizes that the determinism versus
stochastic debate is a total red herring
um well uh okay let me
respond to these
in order i once asked um
julio tinoni
um according to his integrated conscious
is integrated information measure
which i am not a fan of let me say that
um
but in any case scott anderson is not
either and so he's got a blog post on it
um but uh according to his measure
a computer a silicon computer
whether it implements its code in
parallel or in serial
determines whether it's conscious or not
i asked him that point blank and he said
yes that determines whether it's
conscious or not
um
i'm first um responding to that aspect
of my conversation with julio before
getting to a neil um by the way i do
think anneal does some very interesting
work um
but so my reaction to that is
what is gained by defining
you can define words or if you want to
define it that's one of the liberties of
mathematics is to find things wherever
you want
and you could define it so that julio
could say i am by definition correct
that this is consciousness my measure
that's okay you can you can say that and
um if that's your definition that's your
definition
but getting back to what we were talking
about last time persuasive definitions
this also gets back to cyril with his
chinese roon argument which i thought
was completely vacuous
um
if you are to whatever if you are to
give a definition of consciousness
which has
any aspects to it which
if it is going to be restricted to being
a characteristic of the behavior of a
system
of the what rather than the how
then it cannot
differ for a serial or parallel computer
and that's what cyril also missed
if consciousness if thinking whatever
you want to call it
is a what rather than how
and i think it's extremely liberty
liberating as a scientist to conceive of
it that way
then it doesn't matter by definition you
just said no the how is interesting
is worthy of study but it's a different
question entirely from the what
and how these are and these should be
disentangled it is a category error to
mistake the how for the what am i to
understand that another way of saying
that is that if it's a state versus a
process
oh no is that is that false what i just
said like that's not the correct analogy
that's not what i mean to say
you right now
if behind those
baby brown eyes if behind your face
were a silicon computer
that has no consequence to the behavior
of our discussion that's what touring's
great
insight with the turing test is
and the importance of the turing test is
not whether you're using a teletype and
things like that
is to say that as far as he
um alan turing was concerned and there's
a lot to be said for this that is useful
to carve out from whatever you discuss
whenever you just want to discuss about
consciousness it is very useful to carve
out
as its own
phenomenon
call it consciousness prime call it
precon whatever you want to be
where we're just looking at the behavior
of the system
and you can have things ones in silicon
one is instead a real human being
one is instead a simulacrum that's being
controlled by somebody outside the room
looking in wherever you want
that's behaving that same way but if
it's behaving the same way you can't
tell the difference
and so for this
particular aspect of consciousness
it does not make any difference
so the tanoni is actually looking at the
other side he's focusing it's kind of
he's mixing up the two i would say
the how and the want
um
so to me the interesting thing is the
what
you first have that then once we have
that what clarified which we don't have
we don't know how to define even at a
behavioral level what the conscious
entity would be
or so on and so forth we can then start
to look at the how
and that's where neurobiology comes to
play which is anil's
particular
comparative advantage his specialty
and that's a completely open issue
frankly as and one that he's doing work
on
um involving things like predictive
coding blah blah blah blah is how do
neurobiological systems achieve it
silicon computers can achieve the same
what they're doing in a different way
and so it's a different question
then with regard to free will i'm always
interested in whether dota taught
whether they think that whether they
think slash realized so that's obviously
a limited question
that the determinism versus
stochasticity debate is a total red
herring
um to say there's a red herring i mean
that's a extremely loaded leading
question
and i'm going to assume that it does
have that character because of uh
basically word length so to speak a
total red herring for what
um and
it's a question that cannot be answered
i would say that free will is commonly
used in common discourse is what we're
talking about yesterday persuasive
definitions
not yesterday but last time yes people
commonly use free will they're not even
sure what they mean
that some people to some people it is
determinism versus stochasticity
um and that's what they mean that that's
what they mean to other people it's not
whether it's a total red herring has to
do with how you define the concept in
the first place
i don't view there as being a concept
worth discussion
i free view as being pointless come up
with your definition
your definition is going to then say
whatever you want your definition to
mean but it's your definition that's why
i'm saying we should call it what
consciousness rather than how
consciousness
just so we're clear in our definitions
i'm not going to say either one is
consciousness
i'm going to instead just make two
different definitions and say that when
people use the word consciousness they
sometimes conflate things
and free will is far more prone to that
when people use the word free will
there's actually many many flavors they
mean very many different things and they
are ultimately fighting about whose
arbitrary definition to use and that is
an exercise in futility set your
arbitrary definition and then we can
maybe or maybe not say something
um so in any case
it sounds like this question sets you
off
well it does because it's such a waste
of time
it's only it's people are debating
definitions
i don't
life's too short folks
define things wherever you want just be
clear what it is you are defining
and once we have the definition and we
don't have any
definitions have no import by themselves
it's only things we can conclude
starting from the definitions
make your definitions feel free just be
very clear what your definitions are and
then after that there might be some
interesting consequences to
um investigate but to have fights about
definitions is preposterous
and that's what a lot of these
fights really are about is just
definition pushing
let me steal man the definition i up to
just a few months ago i'm on board with
you 100
now let me steal man the definitions
point of view i was speaking to
professor jorah barnatan of mathematics
in toronto here and he was saying i was
asking him can you also in preparation
for our interview tell me which proofs
which theorems are your favorite and
then he responded and said he doesn't
like proofs and theorems and what
standard textbooks focus on he actually
thinks perhaps definitions are more
important or perhaps techniques
i thought you might be going there but
here's what i think he actually meant
he thought that coming up with
definitions that lead to a very rich set
of theorems and proofs that that is the
key to being i mean here is my putting
words in his mouth to being a successful
and important and do important work in
mathematics is to first come up with the
very fruitful definitions i fully agree
that but that is not what people who are
arguing about free will are arguing
about they're not saying for which
definition of free will
and he wasn't actually either your
professor he wasn't saying which
definition
of
um parallel
should i adopt
he was saying no what's important is if
i put together the words in a certain
way
and then i call them what i call them
doesn't matter
but those set of words put together in
this way we'll call it a alpha b beta
we've just defined a alpha b beta if i
can use a alpha b beta to prove a whole
bunch of fruitful things that's a good
definition
these people instead are saying what
should a alpha b beta mean
which is backwards
so that professor um he was saying that
it's not the words it's not the clothes
don't make the man it's not the words
that you're draping this with that
matter is whatever this is
and here people are saying well i've got
my words first and i'm gonna fight with
you about whether um they actually mean
this or they mean that
it's it's useless it's it's backwards
it's not only anti-scientific i would
say it's anti-intellectual almost
now for the sake of playing the devil's
advocate let me know what you think
about this
now when we're not talking about
mathematics something that's
specifically well defined when we come
up with a definition
it works somewhat akin to this we have
an intuitive notion of some concept and
it's ambiguous and then we give it a
name and we usually give it a name by
pointing to different objects that
satisfy what we think is that intuitive
definition so for example with life
we'll say the couch behind you is not
alive you're alive the beetle is alive
the fire is alive
let's say minus 3000 years ago and then
there's other people arguing about that
well the fire is not alive but i do
agree david is alive and i also agree
that the couch is not alive so we have
these volutinous feelings of amorphous
balls and we're trying to see okay well
what's the intersection between us which
one captures what we're trying to say
most which one captures the most
relevant
concepts so that's why there are
disagreements about the definition we're
trying to figure out we're arguing about
what the entries in the oed should be
there's an entry in the oed for life and
what should it be the oxford english
dictionary
and so for example on that particular
topic
um
people do define life as a bit
and i always and the question is well
how should i define that bit if they
want it to always be it's alive or it's
not alive what's how do we define what
one or the other means
so this is a other work of mine earlier
in my career i did with a fellow called
bill mccrady and others have picked it
up since um
so
my reaction to that was that this is
silly definition plugging come up with
your definition and whatever to say
something israel is not alive is silly
um at a minimum if you're talking about
biological organisms
it's not going to be just a single bit
it's going to be actually at least a
real number and well actually it's going
to be a vector we'll actually know it's
going to be some much more higher
dimensional thing
it's not going to be life is a bit
clever life is some
other mathematical structure and here's
one that we happen to come up with that
actually turned out to be somewhat
fruitful another topic of research i
wanted to work with
you know what a fractal is i assume okay
so i take the m the magnifying glass and
i magnify that microscope and i keep
seeing the same thing
let's take that magnifying glass that
microscope
put it on your skin
as we keep running up the power
we go down to the level where we're
seeing now individual cells now we start
going with you know within the cells and
so on
the images in that
microscope keep changing
you are not self-similar you are self
dissimilar
the patterns in you are very different
from one another at each different scale
in fact
that seems to be true of almost all
systems that are alive
it is not true of almost all systems
that are not alive
moreover this self-dissimilarity is a
way to give nuance and structure
to the form of the life
because you can actually be looking at
how is it that the patterns of at each
scale are related to one another you've
got an entire matrix
and so this we called it
self-dissimilarity and we were very
careful not to say it's living or not
and we simply say actually i think we
reverse this effect
any system that does have
self-dissimilarity high
self-dissimilarity
is almost by definition going to be very
interesting
and some people might say it's actually
a complex system but we again we don't
want to be
selling it with these definitions we're
just going to simply say it's
self-dissimilarity
we put it out there as a proposal to the
research community that they shouldn't
be spending all this effort in trying to
figure out what should the definition of
this bit living or not living be
that that's fruitless and it's just
going to be in terminable wars that
never are going to end up
being rich in the sense of definitions
that your mathematics professor was
thinking
but let's instead be thinking about the
self-dissimilarity of different systems
because why would you think that an
interesting living system might be
self-dissimilar in the first place so
it's not just that we can notice
phenomenologically
that living systems are all
self-dissimilar whereas non-living
systems like mountaintops and so on are
so similar we can actually ask why might
that be the case
and so here's a
interesting proposal that i have not yet
time to investigate
what if biological systems this is
somewhat along the lines of the things
that carl fussing is interested in
what if biological systems
had to as a for for um and also for that
mayor donald hoffman had to as an
evolutionary imperative
extract the maximal computational bang
out of a given physical body buck
how might they do that well one thing
you can think of doing is distribute
different parts of that computation to
different spatial locations in that body
and that's what systems do biological
systems to a large degree they have the
computations that are going on your
brain being a different part of you from
the computations that are going on
in your kidney for example you've been
um the computation's been distributed
but you might also not only want to
distribute the computation across
different positions
but also across scales
there might be different and there are
if you think about it different
computations being done by the cells in
you
compared to the computations being done
by the organs in you
moreover these computations being done
at the different scales are actually
communicating with one another
so you can imagine that as an
evolutionary imperative biological
systems would be driven
to want to distribute the computations
that they do
across their different scales as well as
their different spatial position part
positions within them which would then
lead us to start to think about what
does it even mean
to distribute computation across scales
what are the general features of such
systems
and it would lead you down a research
path which i've not had time to go
but it would lead you down a fruitful
greek church path to in fact
um uh refute and and and dispute and
and
um
avow no
to the concept that life can be reduced
to a bit
but we if we start by saying that this
exercise is an exercise in futility
that instead we want to come up with um
not a definition that's reducible to a
bit you are or you are not but rather
look at this much more nuanced structure
it might lead us in much more fruitful
research directions it might be a much
more useful definition
in the sense of that mathematics
professor you're you are describing
before
now if you can answer this one quickly
because this isn't a site about what you
said you mentioned that
it may not be a bit it could be a vector
now i see how it could not be a bit it
could be a real number but i don't see
how is it that this dissimilarity
measure could be a vector like r2 r3 et
cetera ah so here's what i can do
i take that microscope this is an
exercise that we've actually did on
various some image data sets for example
and we applied it to things like the
logistic dynamics and so on and so forth
um take that microscope that's um uh
getting distributions of of the visual
images of the patterns at different
scales
these are now going to be distributions
over the pixel pattern within the
microscope's field of view
now i can there's many measures from uh
machine learning probability theory
information theory for saying how
different two distributions are
so this way i can say for any one of the
following say 10 scales
how different
is the distribution over images at those
two scales so i'm comparing scales
magnification two times a modification
seven times
those scales have associated
distributions over images
i look at how different those
distributions over images are the scale
two times and seven times that gives me
a real number
i then look at it for another pair of
magnifications that gives me another
real number
so in this so in essence what you were
seeing that this pat this set of
of differences between distributions
at the different scales
can be wound up into one actually it's a
matrix because you're putting in the two
scales
that i'm comparing into these elements
of these matrix so for if you give me
two scales i'll give you a real number
it's actually more rich than a vector is
a full matrix a symmetric matrix
um yeah uh yes this particular case is
symmetric exactly so okay so now this
question comes from
kevin knuth and i know you got to go
don't worry i got to go to
kevin knuth
our friend kevin knuth and i'll read it
so he wants to know what is life it's a
question that people have entertained
for a long time without obvious answers
your thoughts on observers i sent them
your video on observers seem to be
relevant i have always thought of living
things as systems that use information
to create some kind of model of the
world around them in order to locate and
take advantage of potential energy
gradients which are then used to keep
them away from equilibrium and i can
give some examples and so on i would
agree that a hurricane is not alive a
hurricane's a heat engine that he's
referencing your talk however it's not
alive because it doesn't use the
information about its surrounding to
model these energy gradients the models
living things can employ are quite
diverse for humans these are our mental
models et cetera et cetera some bacteria
etc so these are my thoughts about life
i really need to write them down maybe
david would be interested in working
with me on this
okay so this these are kevin knuth's
thoughts i'm sure you can pull a
question out from that or just comment
on it as a whole
um
yes so
um what kevin
what he's talking about here first of
all um hi kevin and yes i think we could
have some very interesting discussions
about here um
so as i mentioned before and um okay so
backing it up
kevin is talking about presentation i
made that's where there was observers
and hurricanes and so on
um the observers are what i was there
i'm using as a term to describe
these non-equilibrium steady states
that if you were to um basically in a
judah pearl sense intervene of the
information flow from the outside world
into these systems
they would no longer be at
non-equilibrium they would actually
collapse to being at equilibrium
and we were calling that in this is what
we were calling an observer
this was um
what they were called in this talk of
mine that kevin saw
and um the and we were
making the definitions be
um we were careful
so that we would not i mean the words
observer and alive are being just
mangled around here
but um that we were trying to make it so
that a hurricane is not in a certain
sense observing its environment
um whereas say a paramecium going up a
uh
gradient of um uh food is observing its
environment and is alive
so um
let's see so
well
i am my collaborator artemis kochinski
we're going after in that paper
where we define semantic information and
observation
and so on as a non-equilibrium study is
a system that's in a non-equilibrium
steady state
such that if you intervened on the
information it gets from the outside
world
it would collapse to equilibrium
equilibrium being a synonym for depth
we were saying that those are systems
that are either observers or living or
just generally of interest without using
loaded terminology
um that is all the what
kevin is talking about models that the
system has internally
that is that basically play a middle
step
in the map from the information entering
from the outside to the actions that the
um entity does back on the outside
that a lot that end up allowing the
entity to be away from equilibrium
the model is the way that it does that
it's a way of interpreting what's going
on in the entity in between these steps
of getting information from the outside
and then acting back on the outside
um
what we were
analyzing in our work
deleted that step we were not trying to
say anything about internal models we
were simply saying the end result is
that if you
interrupt the information flow from the
outside
we were saying nothing about the reasons
whether it go through models or some
other
phenomena but the ultimate effect was
that you collapsed back to equilibrium
so it was saying that if you if i sunder
the information you're going from the
outside you're getting right now
information from the outside about where
a cheeseburger is on a table
if i stop that information flow
eventually you die you fall back to
equilibrium
so that's the so what you are doing is
you are right now in a non-equilibrium
steady state because you're getting
information from the outside world and
what i and what we were analyzing there
is systems where if you were to chop
that information flow from the outside
world the result is that they actually
collapse back down into being
equilibrium they die
the means by which that happens
in your particular case or well if you
had that information about where the
cheeseburger is you could then reach out
your hand based upon an internal model
of the outside world grab that
cheeseburger bring it to your mouth
digest it
get a whole bunch of glucose which is
what you then use to stay out of
equilibrium
so that's everything that happened in
between you're getting the information
and you're staying out of equilibrium
in other processes like the paramecium
it's getting information about the
gradient of a chemical in its
environment
it is then using that information one
could maybe say an implicit genetic
model that's what kevin is saying but
whatever the end result is that it uses
that to determine
how it should reorient itself before it
uses this flagella to actually move
so that it can actually then ingest
these particular chemicals and that's
how it stays out of equilibrium
so in my work with artemy kalczynski all
that we did was looked at the um
the beginning point and the end point
notice that you need the information
coming in to stay out of equilibrium
those are interesting systems we said
from a physics point of view
kevin is now discussing is a special
case of such systems
which are physics systems that capture
at least a large part of what is
what one might want to say is a living
system they're not just interesting
these things they do capture a large
part of what it means to be alive
so that's a very long-winded answer to
question to kevin's question kevin yes
if you do want to in particular the
directed information flow of people like
daniel palani and nihai
i think could be a very very interesting
fruitful way to try to build more
structure
into these particular systems
a halfway point to building full-on
internal models
so yeah kevin drop me a line
now the last question you can answer
hopefully fairly quickly it's even
though it's long it's one sentence
it's actually just one sentence so i
love this one comes from professor
edward lee of berkeley i love david how
your work has complicated the faith many
scientists hold in an ultimately
deterministic world i was wondering
whether you've looked at john norton so
we talked about that
so we actually did talk about that in
particular why is this example
controversial why are so many people
offended by the idea of uncaused action
yeah i've also encountered um uh
professor lee's work and i find also
mutual admiration here um that i am
impressed with a lot of his work um this
is actually a subtle thing i'm very
careful in my
stuff on inference devices
there is no laws discussed mentioned
anyway there's no rules
there's no
mathematicalization of the patterns in
the underlying reality
it's just
world lines in a set
and in an observer is one particular um
subset of those world lines something
it's observing is another subset
what it means to observe
has to do with the relationship between
those two subsets
what it would mean to make predictions
would then be another subset
and basically by means of these subsets
and their overlaps that this topology
you would build up the structure of a
scientist using theories to make
predictions about what might occur in
the world and those theories are going
to be in the form of rules and laws
and so for example max tegmark's
multiverse work i highly plug his
foundations of physics paper in the
earlier animals of physics um papers
on the multiverse don't bother with pop
books go to go for the real meat um
in that work
he ultimately
reduces the notion of physical reality
to a set of laws to a set of
mathematical
rules
and the presumption that all physical
reality is is just a set of rules which
is
precisely why
john norton's example is controversial
because it seems to
wreak havoc with the notion that
physical reality can be reduced to a set
of rules
that's i think ultimately from a
sociological point of view why people
are upset about that
i'm very careful in my work that rules
don't appear
there's just subsets there's a topology
there might be patterns those patterns
can be violated at any point in time
no free lunch
um newton's laws even if they are there
they might just suddenly disappear
tomorrow before the um
before uh the ball of john norton has
even had a chance to try to think about
falling off of the dome
um
but many people instead want to
implicitly
they think of a mathematical universe as
being
a set of things like differential
equations
rules laws
and i just think of it instead as being
a set and there can be a topology on
that set
and the topology might have patterns
which you might be able to embody as
such rules and laws
or it might not
it all just depends on the topology and
different topologies are going to
either be rule like or not rule-like
law-like or not law-like
and it's not even the case that one is
real and one is not real they're just
all different realities
it's legitimate to one as legitimate as
one another there's no privileged
reality
i i suspect that
all of these kinds of answers i'm giving
you these questions
are not necessarily fully fruitful it's
kind of
as an aside as an interviewee to give a
answer to a question in a stand-alone
manner rather than in a dialogue
where i can see the response of the
questioner and therefore refine my
answer
accordingly it's a kind of a strange
thing because it's almost like open loop
rather than closed loop control
um but in any case um i hope that
answers a little bit um a professor
lee's question
professor thank you so much for spending
so much time with me and the audience
i'm sure thanks you too
okay well thanks very much sorry if i
was too much open loop control i think i
was a little bit logarettic today but
so uh thank you very very much
and if you could give me the information
about um the forum for this so i can
then forward that to the sfi people and
kevin contact me
great okay okay goodbye professor thank
you okay truly it was a blast like i'm
great to be speaking to someone who also
is philosophically inclined even though
you had your excoriations on philosophy
you still had your philosophy of
philosophy
yeah um in many ways yes
i think philosophy is almost by
definition the most important
intellectual endeavor there is but and
this is being a real snide [ __ ]
i don't i think it's really unfortunate
people that actually engage in it
have not been trained
properly and that's most of philosophers
um it's unfortunately exceptions um you
know dan dan i think
the training can either be explicitly or
implicitly and i think dan is an example
of somebody who's
quote trained well to be really speaking
in snotty asinine terms
um but yeah i think it's the most
important um subject there is
almost by definition
all right take care sir okay
and we'll talk soon bye bye okay thank
you
there were two extra questions from sam
thompson and chris langan that we didn't
have a chance to address on video due to
limited time but david was kind enough
to answer over email
sam thompson asks do you see any
socio-political implications in your
work on the formal limitations of
inference devices david walpart says
interesting question one could consider
for example the laplace's demon theorem
or the monotheism theorem as concerning
limitations of what a government is
capable of but those theorems are based
on worst case scenarios they show that
there is some question-answer pair that
an inference device gets wrong not that
it must get wrong a particular such pair
more interesting and future work would
be an extension of the inference theorem
would be an extension of the inference
device formalism to incorporate
probabilities and degrees of failure
then for example we could maybe get
impossibility results concerning the
maximal probability that the error of
the inference device would be less than
a bound in sociopolitical terms rather
than a result concerning worst-case
failures of a government the current
impossibility theorems we would have a
result concerning the likelihood that a
government failure is worse than a given
amount
now on to the question from chris langan
david you base your definition of
observer on principles of physical
causation including thermodynamics and
statistical mechanics dot david
interjects i've used the term observer
in different ways depending on whether
i'm talking about inference devices or
the semantics of information formalism
with artemy or noisy deductive reasoning
which meaning do they have in mind so
then chris langen finishes the question
do you subscribe to physicalism the idea
that reality is basically physical in
nature or do you think that a broader
more sophisticated understanding of
causality one that exceeds the classical
concept of physical mechanism and
quantum theoretic concepts like
entanglement non-locality and quantum
wave function collapse will eventually
be required david answers in short there
is right now absolutely zero data slash
evidence to believe that will
quote-unquote eventually be required so
occam's razor provides the answer
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you